Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to. Oh, this is
interesting. Let's go to one from my birth city
of Buenos Aires, Argentina. Juan, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hey, David.
So you might know that abortion was legalized in
Argentina last year. I didn't know that. A big a
big part of that movement was like the green
bandanna. Being in Buenos Aires, I saw that
everywhere. And I think that had, like,
a big psychological effect like that. The
green bandanna, like public displays, greatly
outnumbered. Like the blue bandana pro-lifer.
Public displays. Do you think the Americans should
adopt a symbol like that for their protests?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. I mean, I don't think
it's the only thing that should be done by.
But why not? We know those types of things work
and are effective. And, you know, in a sense,
it's a version of the lawn sign. Like, you see
a lot of lawn signs for a candidate. It doesn't
mean they're necessarily going to win. But I do
think people are more invigorated, in a sense,
behind political ideas. When it looks
like there's a community of support. So,
sure, I would be fine with something
like that. I think it would be great.
Speaker 5: Totally awesome.
Speaker 1: So what's
going on? Are you from Argentina?
Speaker 5: No, I'm from Venezuela. Oh, okay.
I immigrated here in 2018 and I really love
Argentina, Amanda. And the cities really
treated me well with pinatas.
Speaker 1: Are you for or
against the raisins in the pinata?
Speaker 5: I'm very against raisins. Really?
The Venezuelan empanada is actually quite
different from the from the Argentine. I I'm a
little biased, but I think ours are better, David.
Speaker 1: But aren't Venezuelan empanadas
typically fried? Yeah. Oh, my God. That's hard
to get. Get me away from that. Why? If it's
not oven baked, put it in the trash one. God.
All right. Thank you for the call, though. I
appreciate it. I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: No problem.
Speaker 1: Okay. There is Juan from Venezuela
now in Argentina. What a beautiful phone call